this video is sponsored by health
journey support a free website where
patients can learn to manage chronic
diseases by watching 3d animations
please visit health journey support com
to learn more
if you or someone you know has high
blood pressure this video will help you
understand what it is and why it's
important to keep it under control
time high blood pressure will damage the
walls of your arteries this damage can
lead to life-threatening conditions
for example an artery wall may become
weak and form an enlarged area called an
aneurysm the wall may burst
and bleed into the tissue around it
in another example damage to an artery
wall may attract certain substances in
your blood such as cholesterol fat and
calcium they may form a buildup called a
plaque
as the plaque gets bigger blood flow in
the artery is reduced
blood cells can stick to the plaque and
form solid clumps called clots blood
clots further reduce or completely block
your blood flow
if this happens in your brain it can
lead to a stroke
it happens in your heart it can lead to
a heart attack in another example damage
to the arteries in your kidneys may
reduce their ability to work properly
this can lead to kidney disease
in a final example damage to your
arteries makes your heart beat even
harder which raises your blood pressure
even more and can lead to heart failure
if you have questions about high blood
pressure or any medications you have
been prescribed for it speak with your
doctor it is important to take your
medications as directed and report any
side effects you have